[Música]
para las tardes
quiero decir algo solamente que tan
nervioso estoy la gente cuando vas a dar
una plática entre idioma normal siempre
sientes nervios o no la imagen sobre
trabajas en una plática en un idioma
donde es batallas porque estoy bateando
el español no pero si vamos a hacerlo
aunque vamos a empezar cuando me
hablaron y él me habló vas a ver una
plática
acerca de las raíces de las veces es muy
interesante porque siempre cuando ya voy
a empezar clases al cuando me estudian
se van a conocerme ya empiezan preguntar
hace que los árabes y como son como
ustedes saben cómo son los árabes ok y
por eso esta práctica así va a ser
acerca de esto me gustaría empezar el
primero con un hombre porque mi nombre
siempre siempre me causa muchos
problemas aquí ok entonces la primera
vez
fue en el 'hms quiero hacer algunos
trámites y entonces fue a las oficinas y
me preguntó la señorita que estaban en
la oficina o que el número de usted le
dijo que quería brahimaj ahmed ibrahim
en salir y me dejó bien espera espera
debo quito a mi objetivo y cuál es tu
nombre y cuál es este apellido materno y
cuál es sabido paterno para saber para
poner el sistema el jockey déjame
explicarte el sistema de egipto como
usamos las nombres allá porque el primer
nombre esta querella es mi propio nombre
mi propio nombre si el nombre brahin es
el propio nombre de mi papá mi papá se
llama brahin y el simple que sigue es mi
abuelo se llaman hammer y el que sigue
el el desa vuelo y el que sigue el final
y el apellido de mi padre y ella me miró
y me dijo que tan feo no es el apellido
materno no es yo lo dijo que como ver
salir de aquí entonces y si por el
contrario igual cuál es el nombre de
usted cómo se llama y él me dijo mi
nombre apellido paterno
el apellido materno esto es que todo el
sistema mexicana porque el nombre de la
padre es el primero y no es la madre la
madre necesita llegar y estar el primer
a nuestra padre que cree que ya me
estaba premiando con ella porque yo dije
realmente el amor de mamá en el mundo
árabe es muy grande no es burgués has
escuchado las mujeres en el mundo árabe
el mujer en tal país es diferente
estoy hablando ahorita en egipto porque
realmente la mujer en egipto está muy
muy fuerte también mi padre infeliz o
falleció cuando yo murió cuando yo
estaba en segundo grado de primaria el
segundo grado y mi mamá tiene que cuidar
seis hijos darle la educación todos ya
tienen la educación imagínate yo soy en
segundo grado mi mamá mantiene toda la
casa mi mamá desde que estaba la jefa de
todo si entonces no como la gente piense
no es las mamás son los mujeres en el
mundo árabe
solamente olvidan los hombres solamente
hacen
cierto y vamos a ver por qué porque la
gente tiene en esta idea ok entonces
este es las problemas que me causa mi
nombre es siempre en estudiantes también
me preguntan y cuando estás en primaria
tienen escribirlo muchas veces porque
está tan largo pero así si escribimos
muchas veces por edades es el de que
hacemos siempre y como la idioma
yo hablo árabe entonces con mi nombre
ellos quiere volar a ver cuándo voy a
firmar entonces ya me dieron un dónde
vais con para escribe para hacer le
asigna y entonces agarré aquí la ventaja
hasta aquí
jagger en la pluma ya voy a empezar a
escribir y un vice de aquí en muchacho
me dijo no no empieza de aquí yo lo noto
porque no voy a salir yo voy a controlar
del otro lado
entonces entonces bien sencilla porque
al árabe scribbos escribimos de derecha
a izquierda sí entonces si éste es las
problemas con mi nombre ok
vamos a ver algunos términos tiene es
causa problemas siempre es la crema de
negro no vamos a empezar con ejercicio
árabe en este egipcio regrese árabe son
los dos pero como estos dos es porque
cualquier persona habla árabe porque
quieren persona el medio ambiente medio
oriente son árabes en todos los países
árabes ahorita está ahora bien uno de
egipto es árabe si entre ustedes aún no
tiene libia uno de sería o no son árabes
porque ellos hablan árabe
sí pero soy egipcio sí porque yo juego
en egipto entonces cualquier persona
habla árabe vive el medio oriente es
árabe porque otras veces árabes y eso ya
gente porque vivo en egipto porque
egipto al que entonces en el mundo árabe
y egipto es peligroso este mundo es
porque van y te van a matar está ya una
guerra y aún entonces mi esposa cuando
el primera vez en egipto
ok para hacer la historia muy corta
conocemos en el facebook y él me trajo
que me voy a ir allá para conocer egipto
entonces ya empezó a hacer el trámite y
sus amigas va a ser egipto sola sabe que
van a arrugar tu pasaporte y no vas a
poder regresar
ortiz a no matar a ella ya muchas
historias porque porque vivieron esto
está en las películas y las fotos y esto
sí pero cuando ya mi esposa estaba ya si
el primer día estamos me estaba
agarrando la mano tiene miedo porque
toda la que echaron la cabeza entonces
el primer día se estaba agarrando mi
mano del segundo día el tercer día y ya
conoció la gente y subo como son
realmente los árabes entonces ella
empezó a correr ya me dejó me dijo ya me
dejó en la caída estaba corriendo solo
en la calle se halla en la mensura
entonces realmente no está tan peligroso
no es peligroso como la gente piensan
aquí cuando me preguntan si está aquí en
méxico registro es de nuevo laredo es
peligroso egipto no quiero ser un
jugador algo así de rafa realmente
egipto es muy es muy seguro porque allá
siempre es algo en la calle que termino
mi trabajo allá cuando estaba en egipto
en términos de trabajo 5 una tarde voy a
tomar una siesta y empiezo media de la
noche en la noche 89 ya salimos se ríen
y luego caminamos a un café y algo
regresamos a la casa como las 23 en la
mañana y no pasa nada si entonces no es
realmente como la gente piensa ok
ese es egipto y ese es el mundo
vamos a ver slam y un musulmán que es la
diferencia realmente es lo mismo slam es
el nombre de religión está el nombre de
la religión
el musulmán es la persona que practica
esta religión si entonces no son algo
diferente como el cristianismo y el
cristiano son sus son lo mismo sí pero
esa es la persona y ese religión
cuando escuchan la palabra de amor
nuestro me dan ya otros problemas si es
porque el muslo man es muy malo lanza
bombas y estoy vamos a ver
una vez estaba en la escuela ya había un
estudiante medio estaba esperando y le
dijo por qué estás esperando aquí
entonces porque nadie va a dar mira y te
estoy esperando haces algo bueno dijo
ven conmigo te voy a darte ahora porque
estás en mi camino entonces y está en el
carro escuchando el corán el corán es
como la biblia se iba nosotros entonces
me miró así y mejor sabe quién es
musulmán y los ojos y soy musulmán eres
malo
de vender entonces yo lo dejo porque
estás preguntando él me dijo es porque
mi abuela me dijo que todos los árabes
todos mis hermanos son malos matan y
esto y él dijo que cuantos árabes cuando
sabes o cuántas mis hermanas con este
trabajo la el viento con nadie youtube
cuando sabes conoces tú entonces tú
conoces maldito la bonita que hubiera
estuvo entonces también es la cosa que
están viendo y voy a hacer porque tienen
este toda la stefan ok
muy bien
vamos a ver después quiero preguntarles
solamente bien salud por cinco segundos
que viene en tu mente cuántos coches la
palabra árabe por la palabra mostró mal
que bien entró en tu mente ok
11 cuando bien se lo voy a hacer te voy
a determinar si y no voy a presentarlo
porque yo sé que están pensando
o que el primero que viene en tu mente
una bomba si este es el primero que
vieron tu mente es porque siempre en las
noticias o no suman a eso estamos en eso
esto orona ahora ve eso esto entonces sí
de tal tanto escuchar es lo que piensas
es el primero que viene en tu mente bien
era el mitin no es no es así porque la
gente piensa el niño y así sale vas a va
a tomar té ayer cómo hacer bombas nada
es tan poco sí
entonces realmente no es así la gente en
el mundo es igual como aquí la gente vas
a encontrar no estoy diciendo que todos
los árabes por todos esos humanos son
muy buenos son ángeles son inocentes no
claro que no
si cualquier beige de que estoy siempre
estoy diciendo a los estudiantes
méxico son sonidos de egipto vas a
encontrar todos los tipos de gente vas a
encontrar gente inocente gente buena vas
a encontrar gente mala pasan con la
gente mentirosa van a encontrar gente
honesta vas a encontrar todos los tipos
de la gente sí pero el estereotipo
siempre es lo que controla todo si ok
entonces ese es el primer que pensaron
cuando escuche esta palabra vamos a ver
qué más
no en un camello escuché ese gesto árabe
el que medió ya brinca en la cabeza
realmente créeme yo he vivido ahora
había vivido en egipto más de 25 años
nunca he visto un cameo en la calle
como pero voy a hacerme como mi amigo
acaba de regresar de egipto y me dijo
que él montó un camello claro que si vas
a ver el camello porque ellos saben
quién es turista van a ir allá para ver
a un camello entonces van a traer un
camello como aquí también cuando gente
van a visitar méxico vale la gente van a
encontrar las sombreros y no sé qué es
porque bien sal todos los mexicanos
tienen sombreros entonces la teoría
también y por el sombrero cuando hablo
con mi amigo en egipto de train y
sombrero como son los mexicanos piensan
que ya está 2 con sombrero va a hacer el
trabajo con sombrero con el cabello pero
no es no estudiar no es realmente no es
entonces es restrictivo de dónde sacan
esto vamos a verlo al final es la media
si está que está diciendo en la cabeza
la gente si otra cosa zach no quejas del
calor de aquí porque en egipto ya
desierto y en mucho calor yo lo miro no
quiero decir lo sabes que no aquí en
nuevo laredo no estoy hablando méxico de
ciudad de méxico tal vez si es mejor la
clima ya pero estoy hablando de nuevo
laredo el lugar donde vivo no aquí es
mucho más calor de allá pero como aman
cómo puede hacer esto estás viviendo en
el desierto va a saber lo que estoy
viendo con camello y cómo voy a hacer
esto y yo no realmente en egipto hay río
ni el origen l desde el sur hasta el
norte
en todo el país y toda la gente toda la
gente viven en las del tas entonces hay
muchos árboles hay muchos en la clima
está muy bien también he vivido sin ayer
condicionarían la casa
ahora aquí si la casa media no tiene esa
condición muero dentro voy a salir mejor
en sol entonces realmente si ahí hace
mucho calor claro que sí en egipto hace
calor también pero no es como la gente
piensa que ya en juárez también dije que
es porque fuera turista en egipto si hay
calor sé claro que si va a ser calor
estás caminando abajo del sol 24 horas
estás caminando 4 es abajo sobre cómo
quiere no vas a ser tú puedes caminar a
quien no hablar en 24 horas en el sol ni
media hora yo estaba jugando fue tocar
con los 100 y está en la escuela mira
como favorece a mi kim entonces entonces
realmente y eso estaba solamente como
media hora aquí en egipto si puedes
caminar y no hay problema si vas a
sentir el calor lo que estás caminando
abajo del sol sí ok
[Música]
ese es el calor en el desierto realmente
si algún par de del desierto claro que
sí pero la gente viven en las del estás
ok ok vamos a ver lo que sigue mucho
dinero
ya yo creía la final de la quincena ya
no tengo nada más
la gente bueno que los árabes vitro
o es petróleo y tiene mucho dinero y
esas cosas realmente si hay
pero no es como la gente bien seguido de
la gente tienen dinero va a seguir hay
agua para salir al mundo ahora vamos a
encontrar ahora ya en la calle o vas a
encontrar a la gente ya en un carro de
oro no realmente no es cierto en
cualquier veis el mismo como el tipo de
la gente en cualquier país vas a
encontrar gente muy rica tiene dinero no
saben dónde van a gastarlo ya hay gente
no tienen que comer hoy ya hay gente
viven normal como nosotros si entonces
el tengo la gente no realmente todo es
muy poquito por un móvil y mentado lo
que tienen la dinero por por por razones
sí entonces también es otro aperitivo
porque qué más
no sé cómo si tienes el aire y es de la
herencia en español muchas muchas
mujeres
yo lo estoy diciendo mismos acaban ni
con una puedo entrar entonces si bien
están también haya hecho puedes tener el
harem de que puedes y no sé qué
realmente si puede pero no es común
nunca yo nunca he visto que no hombre
con dos o tres mujeres ahora si no se
puede a mí no es común si por religión o
por transición también hay así puede el
hombre casar más de bs 3 pero no vas a
encontrarlo no es común si también y
piensa en ella alto no no se pueda voy a
hacer con un grupo mucho dinero aunque
ahí puede volver casarnos dos o tres y
cada una con el palacio ahora algo
sellada porque tiene mucho dinero
realmente no está tan como no no no yo
he visto y he vivido allá más de 26 años
no he visto con uno con dos por tres
no he visto esto entonces también ok de
que estoy diciendo por qué estoy aquí yo
porque estoy diciendo decía para
terminarlo este es es la media
la media que está solamente mostrando en
parte de imagen mostrando solamente un
lado no está mostrando la imagen
completa mostrando solamente los árabes
así los árabes y los árabes así pero no
están mostrando el otro lado
es tan solamente un parte por eso estoy
diciendo nunca juzgar sin conocer sin
conocimiento no juzgas sin conocimiento
anteriormente no juzgas hasta tu vez no
al el día de hoy no juzgues aunque tú
ves porque es porque nosotros como
personas no tenemos realmente no no no
actuamos todos los tiempos como buenos
siendo ustedes surgen de nosotros todo
el tiempo es bueno no tenemos fallas y
hacemos también algunos problemas y
actuamos en malas maneras a veces sí o
no nosotros actúan bien todo el tiempo
yo pudo capturar estos momentos malos
yo puedo mostrarte mira está malo o pudo
capturar solamente los momentos buenos y
demostrarte estos momentos y besarte
sabes que es bueno incluso es la media
está echando la ellos quieren no es no
estoy decir toda la media pero estoy
diciendo la mayoría están mostrando
solamente el equipo
quieren mostrarte que yo quiero un micro
yo quiero mostrar que esta persona esté
presente puedo hacerlo yo quiero mostrar
la mesa una persona que es culpable o
que es malo voy a mostrarlo también
bueno entonces el tema para terminar el
día de hoy es no juzgar sin conocer
tienes que conocer tienes que investigar
para el final puedes llegaron con un
decisión
muchas gracias disparador
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]